Let's write a function that randomly rolls
a six-sided dice and returns a value for that roll between one and six.
We know that it will return one of these whole numbers which are integers.
So let's start by writing our function definition with the return type of int,
and name our function to rollDice.
And this return type means that we expect
a return statement in our function that returns an int as output.
Now, let's start writing the code to generate this random int between one and six.
We can use Math.random to generate a decimal number that falls between zero and one,
not including one exactly.
But how do we get this value to be an integer between one and six?
Well, we know how to create a number between zero and
9.999 from before by multiplying this random number by 10.
So let's use a similar strategy to change this range to be between one and six.
Let's first focus on our total range.
When we wanted to create a range that had 10 total numbers in it, zero through nine,
remember to count zero as an option too,
we multiplied a random number by 10.
So 10 numbers multiplied by 10.
This time, you'll want a range that has six numbers in it, one through six.
So you'll want to multiply by six to get this correct range.
So let's multiply a random number by six,
then the random number here will be between zero and nearly six.
But that's not quite what we wanted.
Because now we've just expanded our range from zero to almost one,
to zero to almost six.
And we want the minimum value of our range to be one, not zero.
And we want our highest value to be merely seven, not nearly six.
So that later, when we cast this value to an int,
a maximum value close to seven,
something like 6.999, will be cast to a max integer value of six.
So we need to shift this whole range up by one.
We can do that by adding one to our random number,
and our adding one shifts this range into the correct place,
one through almost seven.
The next thing we need to do is our casting step to
get the random integer we want without any decimal place value.
And we can cast this number by putting the variable type we want,
which is an int, in parentheses right before the value we want to change, random number.
And that's the same as a value to a variable, randomInt.
And again, even if the double random number value is close to seven,
something like 6.998, when this is cast to an int,
it will turn into six because the decimal portion is ignored entirely.
So now, we have our correct range,
one through six, all integers.
And to return this value,
there is one more step, a return statement.
And for that, we actually say return and then the value we want to return.
In this case, our variable, randomInt.
Great. Now we have a return type and a return statement,
and we can call this function and get a random int as output.
So we wrote a function definition for rollDice.
Now let's call it twice and store the output.
The output should be a randomly generated integer that's between one and six.
So let's store these as int variables, roll1 and roll2.
Let's also include printing code that will print out the value of roll1 and roll2,
and the print output might look something like this.
Your first roll will be at two,
and the second roll is a five.
So even though these two rolls were assigned to the same function call,
each time we call this function,
a new random integer between one and six will be generated.
And that's why these have different roll values.
And if we ran this code again,
new random values will be generated.
So good job. We finished writing a program that can simulate rolling dice.